etc
so first of all now is a very good time
for
questions on anything from the first few
talks that you might have uh
because the
the last talk will
there will be more details and so if
there are confusing things from before
we can cover that first
yes
uh yeah sure so
in fact
yeah i'll be doing that
or at some point during the
during this talk
but
we're actually not going to use the mw
algorithm ever again
uh
but
so what you should actually take away
from the mw algorithm is that it's an
algorithm achieving a certain guarantee
and the guarantee of the following
you have
you have two projective measurements
you have these two measurements
and what that means and they're they're
on the same applied to the same space
right and what that means is that every
is that you can write every state in the
space as a linear combination
of uh
it's a little more complicated in
general but
okay so like you can basically you can
consider what
an arbitrary state looks like in the
in the
jordan like subspace decomposition of
the over space
and so in the in the a version of this
it means that like there are the
there are the eigenvectors that are in
the image of pi a they're the
eigenvectors that are in the
not in the image of pi a you can write
an arbitrary state in this form
and what the marriott watchers algorithm
wants to do
is
mw
wants
uh
to
output
a value p
i
which is going to be
uh like close to
which is going to be
close to pj
with probability like
alpha j 0
squared like with with the with the
probability that that this state was in
like the the pj subspace
the mario watchers algorithm should
output something close to to that value
and the resulting state
after the marriott watchers algorithm
should should be mostly concentrated in
the subspaces with
pj that are with with p value that are
close to sorry pj value that are close
to the number that you got
that's like
that's what the algorithm needs to do
and that's actually all that's the
previous talk is using about the
algorithm like
like in order to like
you know show soundness of the protocols
right down that extract
uh because that's the
because the
so the so okay this is this is the mw
procedure and
alternating projectors were used for the
second procedure which is trying to like
go from
pi a to pi b or something like that i
guess the way it was phrased was
actually you start in pi a
and then you leave and then you want to
come back to pi a like
and uh and for and these algorithms
like can only do that
uh when
like
when these things are actually
projective measurements
and the
like they need to correspond to some
linear space
and uh and the way that we end up it's a
little complicated but the way that we
end up getting this linear space
involves like not just the
like involves thinking like what what
what
the the guarantee you can phrase
is that what you can actually restore is
the property of being in like these high
pj subspaces
rather than just like restoring success
probability which is like a success
probability is like if you have a state
it's success probability is like the
average value of pj over all the
subspaces and that's like not a quantity
that we can like directly manipulate
and so in particular we can't say
that if your average success probability
was p that we can get to average success
probability p later what we can only say
is that if your average success
probability is p
then we can measure pj which is like
sampling from a distribution whose mean
is p
and then we can restore to p j rather
than p
more questions
okay i'll i will i will
i will go on that those were good
questions though so if you have more
questions you should ask them
uh so so so far today what we've seen is
how to prove now that actually a bunch
of protocols are sound against quantum
attacks so we we first saw this um
technique in the in the first talk and
then the second talk uh we saw a much
stronger
like rewinding procedure that could
prove uh like soundness for more
protocols and and like with
quantitatively stronger guarantees about
the sounds
uh
now
at the beginning of today we said we
wanted to understand soundness and zero
knowledge and we've done a pretty good
job at understanding soundness there are
still some open questions but we've done
a pretty good job
uh with zero knowledge we haven't
actually said much we only said that you
can do
watrus for
uh for simulating protocol for proving
that protocols are zero knowledge when
the simulation task amounts to guessing
some some value that that that the
verifier is going to spit out
uh
but
the i would say
you know most
zero knowledge protocols that we have
actually written down do not actually
have this property and and there are you
know there's an entire field of writing
on zero knowledge protocols and there
are many ways of actually doing
simulation and this guessing is is just
the first way
so
that's uh
so that's what we want to figure out for
the last talk
uh so we want yeah we're going to do
more one
so so today we're going to see uh
we're going to keep developing the
toolkit from the previous talk we're
going to sharpen the tools and we're
going to add a couple of new ones and
then we're going to do more post quantum
zero knowledge
uh so
so as we just said uh so if you recall
the bloom protocol example from talk one
and the and the post quantum zero
knowledge simulator we had for it so we
simulated by guessing this string r
uh that's what the simulation task
entails
uh and of course this works when r is a
single bits that that's the actual case
that we covered before
but it also works uh sorry so so first
of all like how does this give you a
real zero knowledge protocol uh
the issue here being that the approver
can trick the verifier with probability
one half so the way that so one way that
just works right off the bat is that you
can get a full zero knowledge protocol
by repeating this protocol many times
sequentially you can show that both the
zero knowledge composes and the
soundness amplifies
and so that will give you a zero
knowledge like a actual post quantum
zero knowledge protocol
uh so so that that's good we have one
uh
the this this rewinding technique also
works when r is more than one bits if
the total number of r
is a polynomial you can carry out a
similar argument
uh
but this doesn't this doesn't actually
like solve
like the i don't know my annoyance
immediately because you still have to
amplify afterwards to get an actual zero
knowledge protocol
uh so okay so what if you want to
simulate when r is arbitrarily long
that's the that's the you know i think
the natural question to ask
uh
so one thing you could say is well it's
literally like take a parallel
repetition of the blunt protocol just do
it many times in parallel but tb you
know large number you'll get good
soundness
uh and so why can't we simulate this
but the answer of course is that you
can't even simulate this classically
uh this is not even classically zero
knowledge but that doesn't include
simulating your quantity you're right
but it's also not constant zero
knowledge
uh
you're right but yes you're right maybe
the quantumness of the simulator
magically allows you to like
avoid this but it does not
uh but at least at the intuitive level
like even classically we can't do this
so you might expect that you have to do
something else
basically you could
keep guessing
yes so you can get an sts post quantum
simulated this way yes
yes
as long as you you know assume the
appropriate two to the t security of the
you can you can you can do zero
knowledge simulation with a simulator
that runs in super polynomial time if
the if the crypto is secure enough and
this will give you some notion of zero
knowledge just for the simulator is
inefficient
okay
uh so yeah so even classically this is
not zero knowledge and in the classical
setting there are two
like main like fixes to this situation
that like exists in the world uh there
are two different like paradigms for
design these are knowledge protocols
ones due to gold right kahan there's
another due to fight and chamier
and uh and both of them like the like
the like one bit that you should have in
your head is that like you fix this
problem by making the verifier actually
in advance commits to which string r
it's going to send they have different
ways of implementing this but they're
that's the they're both trying to to do
that
uh
and so in this case you can show
classically these protocols of zero
knowledge but the task of simulating the
verifiers view is no longer about
guessing the string r we can like r is
too long we cannot guess it
uh
instead the simulation task actually
amounts to extracting the the string r
from the verifier in this setting you
think of r as like a secret that the
verifier knows and doesn't necessarily
want to tell you uh but
but we'll design an algorithm that
manages to extract the secret from the
verifier provided that it's well-behaved
enough
uh and so one consequence of what i'll
show you today is that we can base in
what we can
write down post quantum analogs of these
paradigms
so
that's that's one thing that we're going
to be able to do but i'm not going to
actually talk about that anymore just
because like defining these protocols
and talking about simulating them is a
little complicated uh just to like write
down all the words so instead i'm going
to use like the simplest example of this
paradigm that i can think of
which is a protocol for proving that two
graphs are not isomorphic
uh
so
so we have two graphs and the approver
wants to prove to the verifier that they
are not isomorphic
and so
yeah you may have
seen some version of this protocol
before i mean there's a very natural
protocol which is the verifier sends a
random isomorphic copy of one of the two
graphs and asks the prover just to
output a single bits like which of the
two if g0 and g1 are not isomorphic then
you should be able to tell me which one
h is isomorphic two
uh and so this is uh this is a
sound protocol
uh but it's not zero knowledge because
if the verifier chooses this graph h
maliciously it may learn
information that it's not supposed to
know in particular you'll you can embed
a graph isomorphism problem sort of into
this into this uh protocol and the
verifier can like get a solution to a
graph isomorphism problem that it
shouldn't have
uh so this is not zero knowledge and the
way that you make it zero knowledge the
there are
there are lots of symbols but it's not
actually complicated but the point is
just that the verifier needs to
demonstrate to the prover that it
already knows the answer b that the
approver is going to send like the
verifier wants to test the prover to see
if it can answer b
but the verifier can also show the
prover that it knows the answer in
advance so the way you do that so
that amounts to a claim that h is
isomorphic to 1 of g 0 and g
the verifier can prove this
uh that it that that prove that in fact
it knows which one it's isomorphic to
by just doing a like a blum type
protocol basically so what you do is you
send like pairs of graphs
and the graph pairs are isomorphic to g0
and g1 in some like either g0 or g1 or
g1 g0
and then then the verifier can later
show either that they are both
isomorphic to g0 g1
or that one of them is isomorphic to h
and together that implies that h is
isomorphic to one of g0 or g1 but the
prover doesn't learn which one and so
the protocol remains sound
that's yeah the verifier proves
yeah verifier proves it knows b
true doesn't learn b approver then sends
b
that's the first one
um
so
yes this is the protocol we're going to
think about
and so this is uh so yeah and a quick
aside is that like there is also a
protocol for graph isomorphism and this
is basic this this looks
uh again similar to the blonde protocol
and it also looks similar to this like
boxed protocol that i just told you
about so that it's
pretty similar
uh and using watrus you can show that
that protocol
is zero knowledge but watrus is not able
to show that this protocol is zero
knowledge it's also not able to show for
example that this like dotted box
protocol is zero knowledge because i am
sending a very long
okay so this is the protocol
uh and
it's classically zero knowledge it's
classically even statistically it's it's
zero knowledge against unbounded
verifiers
and yet it is not clear whether it's
post quantum zero knowledge which also
sounds kind of ridiculous uh yeah this
came up in discussion in the first talk
like uh
security against even security against
unbounded adversaries doesn't
necessarily imply post quantum security
depending on what the security
definition is
so here since you want simulation
uh you want efficient simulation of the
zero knowledge means like you can't just
you don't inherit like post quantum
statistical zero knowledge from
statistical zero
uh
so anyway so we have a protocol that
sure looks like it should be post
quantum zero knowledge but it's also not
clear how to prove it
um
and so the intuition for why this is
zero knowledge i'm just talking about
zero knowledge right now uh is that if
the statement is in fact true if the two
graphs are night isomorphic then the
verifier's message h actually defines a
correct answer b like there is no matter
what h is there there is a b defined
that the prover is supposed to send or
or it's supposed to send nothing because
maybe neither b is actually correct but
that's fine
um
and so
uh the classical simulator is going to
rewind the verifier in order to extract
this bit
it's going to
obtain two accepting transcripts for
this box protocol the simulator will
and
and using these two accepting
transcripts you'll be able to
reconstruct b in particular
uh also i should i should be clear when
i'm saying accepting transcripts here i
mean actually approver accepting like
what's actually going like the verifier
is proving something to the approver
the approver only sends b if it accepts
the proof
so we're trying to
extract two accepting transcripts for
this protocol accepting in terms of the
prover
and if we can do that then the simulator
will have learned b and can send it
okay
you can extract the entire isomorphism
you can sorry yes you could you could
just extract the whole isomorphism but
all we need is b
and this turns out to be relevant in the
post quantum setting although is
irrelevant from the classical settings
but there isn't one
no but it doesn't need to be or it can
like
like uh unbounded simulator is fine here
because
because because because the zero
knowledge is statistical it doesn't
matter
the proverb
the the the transcript the prover gets
is literally independent of b
so yeah so more more carefully what the
zero knowledge simulator is going to do
is
it's going to run first of all run the
verifier once
right so we do that
and now
at this point the approver is either
supposed to send b or not if the
verifier convinced the approver it's
supposed to send b if the verifier did
not convince the approver the proof was
supposed to abort if you're supposed to
abort you abort easy
uh so the
however in order to get a correct
simulation
if
the prover here is supposed to send b
then the simulator has to find b
it can't just like go back and try and
try again because then you'll skew the
distribution of transcripts like at this
point you really need to find b and
there's no way around
and so what you do
is
sorry is you is you then just run the
verifier over and over again
until it provides you a second accepting
transcript and you learn you really do
not stop until it provides you a second
accepting transcripts
and then uh
since you know similar to blum this
protocol this box protocol is is two
special sounds so once i have two
transcripts i find b and b
is what the simulator outputs and then
we're
so that's the classical simulator
uh
and so and so you can see that the task
of the simulator here is that of
extraction
and it's a very strong form of
extraction you need to like conditioned
on some initial
events you need to always extract
uh and so and
and so and just to make sure this is
actually efficient we need to calculate
the runtime of this uh
of the simulator and so if the verifier
was is epsilon likely to make the prover
accept in other words to actually make
the prover have to answer
then the with probability one minus
epsilon the simulator doesn't have to do
really any work
and then with probability epsilon the
simulator has to rewind about one over
epsilon times to get a second transcript
and so the expected run time is nice
because you get epsilon cancelling with
one over epsilon and everything's good
so this is the the classical signature
uh and so the takeaway here is that the
zero knowledge of this protocol is
really equivalent to some or like
basically equivalent to some sort of
soundness property of the box protocol
and by by soundness that i actually mean
is proof of knowledge rather than
soundness but don't worry about it if
you don't know the term it doesn't
matter
um so yeah so the task is literally find
be an expected polynomial time and in
the quantum setting we want to be able
to do that without changing the verifier
state because that's what the simulation
task actually requires from us
and the yeah so the expected polynomial
time and without disturbing the states
are there like two key like conditions
that are different from the setting of
the last talk
here that you don't change
because once i finish the simulation i
just output b
and then that's ah because
what i want is the verifier state just
after the first execution
right i do one execution and and now the
in the real world i would send b and the
verifier state would be the state after
one after that one execution
so i need to make sure i get that state
just put the simulation
that's the way the simulation says yes
that that the state is just part of the
verifier view we need to simulate
okay so for the rest of the talk uh
we're going to
do the following things
uh
first
uh we're going to solve an easier task
than the full simulation task
which is just
uh
basically the first
just solve this part just find the an
expected polynomial time and not worry
about the states
so of course this is clearly a strictly
easier problem than the full problem but
it also turns out that in pretty high
generality like this problem like modulo
some potentially some like cryptographic
arguments this problem is like the key
step and that once you solve this
problem you can also
preserve the verifier state
uh so in step two we'll show that
and and at that point we we have a zero
knowledge simulator
um and then finally we'll talk about uh
like uh like some serious like com
actual like computational model issues
that come up when uh when writing down
the simulator uh
it turns out that quantum expected
polynomial time is actually like a a
pretty weird object
okay so but first let's just do
let's just extract with high probability
were there any questions
uh so
so what we'll do is we'll define
precisely what this extract with high
probability or guaranteed extraction
means
uh
and then we'll uh
like uh
relitigate the last talk basically
and like and and
give a more abstract formulation of what
those kinds of rewinding algorithms are
capable of doing
uh
and then in particular we're going to
like abandon marriott watchers and start
using these singular vector like
like singular vector transform
algorithms
uh and then
on top of that then we're going to
understand that like the rewinding
like procedure from the last talk is
sort of is pretty fundamentally
incapable of actually doing this
probability one extraction we're gonna
have to write down a new extractor
okay so that's what we're going to do
uh so quickly uh so we'll define
guaranteed extraction
so
if you think about what we just
discussed about the graph
non-isomorphism simulator what happened
was that the
adversary was one run run once
and then conditioned on it like
producing an accepting transcript we
then wanted to extract that bit always
so
uh
so we're going to write down some
some definition which which captures
this but in the quantum setting things
are we have to change the definition of
the quantum setting
uh if you naively write down like a
variant of this classical definition
it's probably unsatisfiable uh just
because of the state disturbance that
comes from writing down this uh this
initial like except like uh accepting
execution
um so instead what turns out to be
possible
is the following definition we're gonna
write down an extractor
such that okay such that the following
happens so we're starting with a
protocol that has three messages right
and we're only rewinding the last two
this three could be a four don't worry
about the three but we're only rewinding
in one step
um
so let's say we have the prover write
down the like initial part of the
protocol execution so that we're at the
step that we're going to be doing
rewinding
and now
normally what you do is you send the
prover a random message and see what it
says
instead what we're going to do here is
we're going to send a superposition
a uniform to a position over messages so
uh
like as opposed to like a classical
random string
and we'll run the prover in
superposition
on these on these challenges and also
not measure like we're also like that
we're running the prover unitary
right and we're writing we can write
down what it would have answered on to
another register as the z
uh and now we'll do is we'll just do the
lazy measurements we'll just measure
whether the transcript would have been
accepted
and uh if this measurement is zero we
don't care what happens anymore that's
analogous to the previous like classical
definition
uh but if the measurement outcome is one
then we're going to manage to extract uh
like a witness
uh
with probability one like conditioned on
this initial execution so sorry i guess
we're like implicitly here we're proving
we're proving uh the prover is proving
like a np statement x is true and has
some
the way i'm thinking about it the prover
has an np witness w what we're trying to
extract is w
okay so so this is the
this is the syntax of the guarantee that
we want
about uh
like about extracting from uh from
approver um
are people clear on what this definition
is saying i'm going to say one is
literally one or one minute yeah one
minus negligible is fine or the the
literal
the yes
yes
and yeah so we want we want there to be
negligible error
in the sense that if
the first measurement is one there's
only a negligible probability of a
failure
and we also want the extractor to run an
expected polynomial
okay so that's the this is the
definition
and uh
oh did i forget to eat i forgot if i
gave the citation at the beginning of
the talk this is joint work with fermi
and nick spooner
sorry if i forgot to say that
you did okay
uh so
so what we show is that like under
fairly general conditions uh you can
actually write down an extractor of this
form for a for a
three or four message protocol
and that can and the conditions were
pretty implicit in the discussion in the
last talk like the last talk was not
nothing was it wasn't particularly
special that we were discussing
killian's protocol then there are sort
of two key properties that you need
one is that
sufficiently many accepting transcripts
will allow you to reconstruct the
witness that's called sp k special
soundness
and the second
condition you need is some form of
collapsing that you are allowed to
measure responses provided that they're
valid
and uh
now i'm throwing a bunch of details
actually under the rug here there are
various like pairs of relaxations to
these notions that sometimes you need to
work with but let's not worry about it
morally this is what you mean
uh and yeah and you can usually finagle
your stuff to into satisfying this
k here could be could be large yes k is
a k could be unbounded polynomial but
should be polynomial
it
yeah there's
when you think about how long the
extractor takes yeah there's a there's a
runtime dependence on k
and but the more insidious runtime
dependence is on epsilon which is the
probability that the prover sends you a
accepting response at the beginning
so this is what we're going to show
and of course the first question should
be did like did the second talk already
solve this problem
uh and the answer is if only life were
so easy
uh
so
so there are there are basically two
there are two concerns here one is
that's is that in the last talk the last
talk was focused on just proving a
different like security property it did
not have this property in mind and the
algorithm that it wrote down does not
syntactically solve the problem like
that it just it doesn't have the the
there is no initial run of the protocol
and there's no conditional like
probability one of accepting but this is
more of a syntactic issue and you can
you so you can cert you can change the
extractor so that it looks more like
what you want here
and then the second issue is that when
you do that
it's still
like it does not satisfy this definition
the issue is that it will not run an
expected polynomial time which uh which
might sound weird because everything in
the last talk ran in polynomial time but
in this setting it does not run expected
polynomial time
what is what is collapsing again
it says that says that if you know the
if if you have the prover state which is
guaranteed to give you an accepting
response z
then you can measure z
and not change the state
uh computationally so the state after
measuring z is computationally
indistinguishable from the state without
measuring
so
so that's our that's our status
uh so let's do a how am i doing on time
let's
when did we start
okay
okay so let's do a q a quick recap of
last talk
uh so
so now we're just we're just trying to
extract many transcripts from approver
states that is relatively convincing
so we start with some proper states
and the
the like the key or there are a couple
of key ideas but the like one of the key
ideas is that this like the success
probability of this prover
is not a real physically accessible
quantity
uh this this gamma that you start with
uh and uh it turns out that like the you
should think about success probability
as actually an eigenvalue and a certain
jordan decomposition of the prover space
uh so we can do that by writing down the
two
uh projective measurements that
corresponds to measuring whether
uh
the prover would produce
a valid answer on like an accepting
response
on the challenge that it was sent so
this is a measurement on a space which
consists of the prover states along with
a register containing a challenge r
so there's the accept measurement which
says would the prover produce an
accepting response
and then there is the uniform
uniform challenge measurement which just
checks whether the challenge register is
in uniform superposition which if you
start with just the prover states tensor
the uniform superposition this is
certainly the case
uh
so
so by jordan's lemma we can write down
the in our initial states in this jordan
basis corresponding to these two
measurements
uh and so
uh the
the eigenvalues pj associated with these
vj states are the actual success
probabilities that will actually be
working
um and so the way the extractor works
is by
first
measuring a value p
using this marriott watrous alternating
projector algorithm
and the guarantee you get from this from
this uh
mario watchers procedure is that if you
get p
then the state you have afterwards
uh
is is a you know is it is still a
supervision that you can still write in
this jordan basis
and you'll have the property that's
like uh almost all of your mass
will be in subspaces these subspaces j
such that pj is at least p
almost all of your mass will be in these
subspaces
in fact the way that we talked about it
that pj will actually just be very close
to p but the important thing is that
it's at least p
minus epsilon or something
okay and the rest of the procedure is
going to maintain this environment we
always want to have approver states with
this where the where you're like if you
uh look in the jordan basis almost all
of your mass is above the threshold
uh and so
then the rest of the extractor of course
is so the extractor wants to generate
transcript so the next thing we do is we
try to generate a transcript meaning we
feed the prover state a random challenge
and
see if it'll give us something good and
and measure if we get it if we get an
accepting c
and then we need to fix like this uh
this step two
like broke the invariant and so we now
need to repair the states to get the
invariant back
and uh and that's how uh that's how this
works that's how the last talk worked
and in just a little more detail like
the
the way that you repair
is by looking at a second
uh
jordan like uh
like a second jordan spectrum
corresponding to two different
measurements
and the measurements are not on the
they're not even on the same hilbert
space that we started on these met the
the so there's the unif except like
jordan decomposition
where the like space of things you care
about are prover states and challenge
and and challenges
uh
the second case what we care about
is
the
space corresponding of the approver
states
and a register
that you can use to run the marriott
watchers algorithm
because the invariance that we're trying
to restore
is like fairly equivalent to the
statements that if you ran marriott
washers you would get a large number
that's basically what you want to say
and so we convert that into a projective
measurement by putting a workspace
register for the marriott watchers
algorithm
which is the thing alternating these two
measurements
and then we define a measurement which
corresponds to whether running marriott
watrus would give us a large number
which is the thing that we want
uh and then we write down a second
measurement which corresponds to like
the event that we just generated in step
two right step two was a disturbance
away from
the image of this pi p star projection
and the disturbance put it into a sub
the subspace pi r b
which uh which is checking two things
one that the workspace register is zero
which is which it can be
and two checking that the approver would
answer the challenge r
either correctly or incorrectly
depending on what actual outcome we got
so
that allowed us to define these two
measurements on this larger hilbert
space
and to repair the states we then
alternate these measurements until we
get that the
thing we want is true that or
and there are details that i just
skipped over but that's that's the high
level of what's going on
okay and so
uh
[Music]
and so yeah so in particular yeah so we
exactly what i said we start like
before step two we satisfied the
invariance we were in pi p star
almost in pi p star uh then we disturbed
it with this with this
rb
measurement
and so the return to subspace discussion
that we had in the last talk says that
we'll be able to return to pi p star in
a reasonable amount of time
okay so that was
talk to in five minutes
uh
okay so uh
so that's that's what we had so first
let's fix this syntactic issue that
we're not like we're not like this
procedure wasn't even trying to get
guaranteed extraction like there there
was actually no guarantee you did not
have a guarantee that you would extract
something in this procedure and if you
look at what i was just saying it might
be totally unclear why like it look kind
of looks like i'm always going to you
know restore the state and keep getting
transcripts
the the issue is actually coming from
just the very first step which was to
write down a number p
and then have and then have the like
initial condition for our invariant
so the question is
how long are we supposed to run
this estimation procedure for
we didn't say
uh
and what what you actually know is that
if you want to estimate this value to
within epsilon
you can do this in one over epsilon
square time with alternating projectors
uh
and
so now the issue is
if we don't know anything about the
initial prover we do not know what
epsilon we need to pick we do not know
like to what level of granularity we
need to estimate this number
uh
and so
there is not actually a specified like
i'm not like yeah so for the problem
that we're dealing with right now it's
actually not clear how long we're
supposed to run this for
uh
yeah we want we really want to guarantee
for any proof
and so the way we're going to do that is
by well you know unsurprisingly actually
matching the definition that we're
trying to achieve which is that instead
of just like starting to extract we're
first going to run
the protocol once
and check whether the prover ex like
will would produce an accepting
transcript
and then only estimate this value p
afterwards
uh and uh and we're going to show how to
do this in expected polynomial time uh
it's it's yeah it's
it's not too hard to do that particular
thing in expected polynomial time such
that you'll
like so you're running for a variable
amount of time but you'll always run for
enough time that you can estimate this p
to like the accuracy that you would want
uh
so
the procedure then is going to first
run through the protocol and check if
the prover succeeds that is literally
applying this accept measurements that's
how it's defined
and we only try to extract if it outputs
one
uh and now what we'll do so so now it's
it's also instructed to think about what
our state is at this point
because i wrote down what psi plus r
looked like in the jordan basis but we
can also think about what this new state
looks like in the jordan basis
the new state is nothing more than pi
except applied to our old state because
i threw everything out
if the outcome was not one
so
uh
so it turns out that the state that you
get
in this case is first of all like the
so we start in a superposition of these
vj eigenvectors which are in the image
of uh pi unif
that's one of the two projectors in the
decomposition
and we applied pi accepts to it so now
we're going to be
like in a superposition of eigenvectors
wj that are in the image of pi except we
we switched from the unif to the except
like
basis of the two-dimensional space uh
and the and this linear combination gets
reweighted by square root of pj
and the reason for that is is just that
the
probability that
uh pi accepts outputs one on vj is
defined to be pj
and so when you like apply this
projection that means that you rewrite
by square root of the probability
so in any case this is what the state
looks like
uh
and so now we're going to alternate
we're going to run the estimation the
same estimation procedure and we're
going to measure p
and we're going to run for an unbounded
amount of time
now so what does unbounded mean what it
actually means is that we're like if you
recall this procedure is trying to
estimate you know
you're trying to estimate this number
and the estimation comes from writing
down like a rational approximation
and so we're going to stop when the
numerator of our rational approximation
is large enough it's going to be at
least like some like security parameter
so i'm like reason you'll you'll have
seen
many
uh
bit flips
or not flips rather
that's what we're doing we're going to
do them we're doing a multiplicative
approximation but the multi so okay
basically a multiplicative approximation
of p
it's going to run in time one over p
but if p a priori is undefined and
that's bad
yes we're going to do it without knowing
p but the run time is implicitly going
to depend on p because the the run time
does is is not fixed
yes so one over p is okay for you but
one over p squared is not
well yeah it's going to turn out that
one over p is okay and the reason is
because of this re-weighting it's only
okay because we forced the pi accepts to
happen if we if we didn't do this step
then one over p is not okay either
because p could be anything it could be
infinite
uh so one over p could be big
um alex yes so you're saying that your
success you want to succeed uh assume
that step zero passed or
uh there's something that i'm missing
yes yes yes i'm i'm assuming that step
zero passed or i'm defining the state to
just be like throw it to just be like
zero in the event that it doesn't pass
and this is a and to be clear this is a
sub-normalized state yeah okay sure i'm
just like discarding the events
where we don't want to extract
okay
absolutely yes we've designed a
procedure that runs but implicitly runs
in time one over p with probability
proportional to p and that's why
everything is okay
so this is fine the expected exactly as
we said
in the pj subspace this algorithm is
going to run in time lambda over pj
and so since the
amplitudes are d weighted by square root
of pj the overall expected runtime is uh
is polynomial and life is good
so
all of this is fine this is a fairly
minor modification to the last talk and
so now we have something which you'll
actually always
uh
which will always uh
explain always extracts many transcripts
and therefore
and empty witness
so
maybe it sounds like we're actually done
uh because
uh because
because now we're never failing
however we have not analyzed the actual
running time of the
like of the full extractor
okay so
uh i think maybe the best thing to do
here is for i mean i i wrote down a
calculation on the on the slides but
maybe it's just best if i write down a
tiny bit on the board and we can hand
wave we can hand way this um so yeah so
let's
let me just write down a little bit
about this
so
so
what is the running time of this thing
the real question is how long
is repair
how long does it take to run repair like
this is the this is the bottleneck this
is the bottleneck operation and the
procedure
and uh and then the other question is
how many times do we need to repair
so okay the answer to the first question
is fairly simple
uh
we want say that we want k accepting
transcripts
then
how many times do we need to repair
anybody want to tell me how many times
we need to repair
the answer is k divided by
the
the probability
right this is how many we need uh we're
so i guess to be clear p here
is the
output
of the first estimates
everything because after we've estimated
p p is basically the success probability
and everything from now on is going to
the running time is going to be a
function of p
okay so we need to repair k over p times
because
only only uh
only p fraction of the transcripts will
actually be accepted
cool
now how long is repair repair turns out
to be order one
so the state you have is a p accepting
state in other words if you run the
whole process you will get an accepting
transcript
that probability
yes yes that's right
okay so
uh fermi showed last talk that if you
start in a subspace and you want to get
back to it you can get back in order one
time that sounds really good uh but
order one time then to order one time
when you treat the
the measurements
as unit cost
so the question is actually what is the
complexity of this
pi p star measurement this pi p star
measurements was the thing which runs
an estimation and checks whether the
outputs is large
so
the so the answer is that this runs in
time
one over
epsilon squared
where epsilon is the accuracy
if you want an epsilon accurate
estimation you need to run in this
amount of time
and now how accurate do you need to be
well you need to be sufficiently
accurate so that even after you do
k over p repair steps
you still have a good probability
of outputting one
and so what that means is that you want
to set epsilon to be something like
one uh sorry to be something like p
squared
because you're going to lose an epsilon
factor one over p times
and so this is actually one over p to
the fourth
so in other words it runs for a long
time
uh
so now that now we can just write down
the total run time in the
given that we have this p output
the runtime is just going to be k over p
times one over p to the fourth
and what that means is that if you think
about the overall expected running time
well then we need to consider the
distribution over p outcomes that we got
and what we know and we and we we
already wrote that down so we we know
that the actual expected value is the
sum over alpha j squared times pj times
this number
and this is uh
so
that is why we do not run an expected
polynomial time we actually just run an
infinite time
uh
p could be just like a arbitrarily bad
small number and this could be
absolutely terrible
okay
so
so that's that's where we are
so now i can skip all of this
uh and so
so here's where we are uh classically
when you want to extract k things
if the proof was successful probability
epsilon you just run it one over epsilon
times and conditioned on the epsilon
event just gives you a nice runtime
here we have something horrible
uh and so
uh
in the end we actually find a way to get
expected polynomial running time
uh
and
the natural thing you would think is
well
well what you'd like to do
is
with probability epsilon rewind k over
epsilon times
and have the rewinding cost be like
polysecurity parameter like not not
growing with epsilon
or not growing with one over p or
whatever uh and that would be nice if we
have no idea how to do that
uh so what we actually do
is we
only rewind k times
we get k transcripts with only k rewinds
so this is like a very like not
classical rewinding algorithm
uh
and so we yeah like literally every time
that we that we like obtain a transcript
it is always accepting
uh and then we only have to repair also
k times and then we like
uh
managed to like get the repair time in
this situation down to one over epsilon
rather than order one and that's until
we get this different epsilon times one
over epsilon cancellation
i i know you're improving the one over
small to the four to one
so so so so i am so in particular in our
rewinding procedure
the like the the
analogous statement here
it will not like it will not have the
property that you can rewind in order
one indications of the projectors
so indeed we are actually moving we're
also moving things around like uh
because it
somehow like the fact that this number
is a constant means that you can't make
it smaller and so you can make the
overall thing smaller if you make this
number bigger and then make it smaller
so yes the answer is you do move things
around
anyway it didn't have to make any sense
we do a bunch of stuff um
so yes
so you said that the expected work is
really high because p could be arbitrary
low right
um so if these arbitrary allow couldn't
it happen that m accept would have
i guess i don't have it written down but
it but the i mean it is it is the the
our state was d waited by the square
root of pj if pj is tiny that's a lot of
de-weighting
but the problem is that you don't know
like or you like
the
because we're trying to always extract
right we're allowed a negligible failure
probability but you that doesn't tell
you like when like just because you so
you measure p you get a number
there's no systematic decision you can
make about like when you should just
give up
uh that would allow you to like make the
kind of argument that you're talking
about
uh and so the that's why instead you
have to get this d waiting
like
number to cancel out with the like
inverse one over p running time
because there's no there's no decision
the precise issue that there's no
decision point where you can say no i'm
just going to not extract here
okay
so so let me give
uh a couple of ideas
uh about how this works
um
so first of all
uh we're like although we loved our
alternating projectors for the first two
talks we're actually going to abandon
them now
uh so
actually if you think about what the
alternating projector algorithm is doing
it is actually achieving three different
guarantees in three different settings
now like for the like current template
that we've written down
and so what you can do is you can just
actually write down precisely what you
want as like an abstract algorithm
operating on like vectors in some like
uh in some hilbert space with it with a
jordan decomposition that you care about
so in general
like the the operations that you care
about are one sort of approximately
measuring like the pj like the pro like
the or the or the or the angle in the
jordan subspace
uh that's what the estimation procedure
is doing
and we also care so then
the second like algorithm that we
actually want is an algorithm which
accepts if your eigenvalue is
large uh
yes
uh and so you can actually can actually
phrase the it turns out if you if you
think about what we actually you can
phrase this as more of like a gap
decision problem where you want to
accept if the eigenvalue is large and
rejected the eigenvalue small
um and this turns out to be what you
need to actually implement this pip star
map
so this is not so different from the
first bullets but it but it's different
enough that it actually matters
and then finally uh the last thing that
we want to be able to do is that if you
start in
pi a
in the image of pi a you want to be able
to get to the image of pi b
uh
although before it was phrased as as
actually like going from pi a to itself
yeah sure maybe some some uh some
variant of that statement would also be
sufficient
uh but you can you can always sort of go
between these two things if you want
and this is what you need to prepare
so these are the algorithms that we need
and
we can describe the rewinding algorithm
completely in terms of these abstract
procedures
and it turns out that if you abandon
alternating projectors you can actually
do this faster um so
i've just given like one possible way
you could actually do these three things
uh using like the least amounts of
quantum machinery possible if that's
what you happen to want
so
uh both like the
the first two algorithms can be thought
of as some kind of phase estimation uh
where you can get a quadratic speed up
over what you would uh over what like
the
alternating measurement algorithm using
stuff like with some clever use of the
fourier transform
uh
and
then the last thing uh is sort of like a
fancy like amplitude amplification type
problem i think like grover's algorithm
so we had alternating projectors to like
cause an event to happen but if you had
searched for the event with grover's
algorithm you could have gotten it
square root faster and i'm throwing some
details under the rug here because the
specific guarantees that we want are a
bit different from what's standard in
the literature
mostly because we want things to always
happen with like one minus negligible
probability we have no knowledge about
what these eigenvalues actually are and
we want them to work like what these
algorithms to always work
but like another like instead of like uh
if you wanted like the shortest
description you could instead
uh turn to this wonderful paper uh on
the quantum singular vector
transformation and there are
there are you know a whole bunch of like
very useful algorithms in this paper
that's like mostly do what we want and
with some like slight like additional
work you can like use these algorithms
to to get all the guarantees that we ask
for
so okay run the numbers
and now
are you gonna say more about the three
uh
the word the words are more like just
like what they would have been called if
you were a quantum person but i already
told you what the the
these are the
these are the algorithms the algorithms
need to do these things right then what
what is the runtime of these things the
next slide yes
so uh
so
uh you can
so in the pj so the alternating
measurements estimated pj and time one
over pj but you can do it in time one
over root pj
uh
this this is another estimation type
algorithm but it's like a it's like a
gap promise gap problem and so you get a
slightly different uh slightly different
running time
um
like the
yes anyway this is the running time that
you get it's a function of the like of
the
initial value and the amount of error
you're willing to tolerate
uh and uh
but more like the yeah and then finally
uh the
when you alternate projectors in a pj
subspace it takes you one over pj time
to go from pi a to pi v
and with a grover type algorithm you can
do it in time one over the pj
although actually like secretly in to
run this algorithm you also need to run
this algorithm
because you don't have a you have no
bound on pj at the beginning you need to
run for an unbounded amount of times
what you actually do is you run this
algorithm and then you run grover's
algorithms
what is sorry no or no so you start with
a c you start with a superposition oh
sorry yes pj is the eigenvector of vj
sorry sorry eigenvalue of
vj yes so anyway you can get some speed
up
and so then we can you know do the same
calculation and uh
if you do the calculation uh
you will
improve this one over pj to the fifth to
one over pj cubed
and uh
and so life is still bad
nice try
uh
so
actually
uh
now i'm gonna tell you something that
sounds uh upsetting which is that's like
it seems like there was no point in
doing any of these calculations like
this rewinding template like should
never like cannot possibly work
and the reason is simply what we've
already said we need k over p
transcripts
is probably not going to run in constant
time
it runs in very not constant time right
now
in particular everything we've done so
far in repair requires running at least
one estimation type algorithm which is
not constant
and so
then if you run the calculation whatever
this like super constant running time
for the repair procedure gives you
will like result in an unbounded running
time and so things actually seem very
bad
uh no matter how clever you are with
your quantum algorithms you cannot make
this expected polynomial time
uh so
uh
so the last thing to to mention is that
our rewinding was simply too classical
uh in order for this to work like uh in
like the it's sort of what we already
discussed like uh
we do not want to repair k over p times
this is just too much so we're going to
refer repair fewer than k over p times
we're actually going to repair only k
times
and the way that we do this
is by giving up on the notion that
to extract the transcript you should run
the prover on a random challenge and
hope
that it gives you an accepting
transcript
everything we've said so far has always
involved doing this
and this turns out to be the wrong thing
to do if you want to extract in the
quant setting as fast as possible
instead you can actually think of
that problem of generating an accepting
transcript as another instance of a
singular vector algorithm uh this time
in the accept uniform jordan d like
jordan like uh subspaces
uh you start like you think of yourself
as starting with a uniform challenge
and trying to get to a state
where the challenge will definitely be
accepted like well the approver will
definitely answer the challenge
correctly
and so that's the key step to actually
getting an expected polynomial runtime
uh so this is really using the quantum
nature of the yes at some point we were
calling this quantum quantum rewinding
but then the like a subsequent work then
needed to be called quantum quantum
quantum rewinding
uh so
yeah so so at a high level our extractor
what it does is we start with the
adversary
states and we consider the adversary
state and tensor product with the
uniform position of challenges
and now and so the
natural thing to do would involve
measuring the challenge register which
is equivalent to sampling a random
challenge and then checking whether the
approver would give an accepting
response but instead of that
uh we're going to okay first of all
we're going to we're going to estimate
we always have to estimate otherwise
life is bad
um and now instead of
checking whether the prover would answer
a random challenge correctly we're going
to run a singular vector transform that
maps the states onto a state which is
guaranteed to produce an accepting
transcript
so
now note that
in this state the challenge register is
entangled with the prover states and so
things are weird
but
you know that if you were to measure the
challenge register and then run the
prover in this uh in this situation
you would get an accepting answer
so
uh given that what we can what we'll do
is we'll now instead of you know before
we sample the challenge and then measure
the answer here we produce an accepting
transcript and we measure we measure
both the challenge and the response
and at this point we then want to repair
the prover back to being uh like having
high eigenvalues
uh and we'll do this and and this will
roughly be the the algorithm but what's
completely not obvious is that is this
like how long this takes uh the the
analysis that in particular what's
really weird is that this is not
a binary we did not disturb our prover
state by binary measurements
we measured a whole challenge and a
response and so
like like the way we analyze things is
going to have to change
but it turns out that if you use all the
fastest possible literally the fastest
possible algorithm for all the tasks
that exists
and you analyze things very carefully
and you observe a minor miracle uh you
can actually show that this repair is
exactly the amount of time that like the
the largest amount of time that would
still make the whole thing expected
polynomial
uh so
in like a few words like let me say a
little bit about why
this is fast
and the the key the key thing or what or
how to analyze the runtime and the key
thing is to understand how to reason
about this measurement
because
we are no longer in the situation of
like alternating it doesn't seem like
we're in the situation where we're just
always alternating binary measurements
or
reasoning about just binary measurements
having been applied because we're
measuring this challenge register
so
so yes we have this return to subspace
principle which says that things should
that if you start in a place and you
leave it by making a small disturbance
then you can get back relatively quickly
uh so
uh
so so that's good and uh but we don't
but it doesn't seem to apply to our
situation
and so the way that you actually analyze
this or the way that we analyze it
anyway
is that
we could run a thought experiment and
say that you know what we have this
state this like after getting an
accepting transcript and measuring it
uh and we can think of this state
as instead like having come from
like
we show that there exists this imaginary
states which is not actually used
anywhere in this algorithm
such that the state we get here
is what you would obtain by making a
small amount of disturbance
to this imaginary state so
and
the imaginary states
is
in the p good subspace
so we prove
that yeah just like in the ether there
is this p good state
such that and some like
not too bad disturbance to it
such that the state we get here is equal
to like that procedure applied to the
imaginary states
and that allows us to prove
that we will be able to return to the
good subspace where return is in a
figurative sense imagining that we had
actually started from this fake state
that doesn't actually like exist in the
algorithm
this is called the su we call this a
pseudo-inversely so it comes from like
appropriate like notion of pseudo
inverse for pi probably
uh so that's uh
and
and the way and the way that the fast
like repair algorithm works is that if
you have uh like uh
log one over p bits of disturbance you
can repair in time one over root p and
that's how we're getting that like
that's a one of the major sources of
runtime savings
okay so and
actually this is not even the full like
thing because you actually it turns out
have to also like calculate how long
repair should run for before actually
like making the disturbing measurements
that causes repair to be necessary but
i'm not let's skip it
stop right yeah yeah so okay
so finally uh all this was about
extracting with very high probability
but if you
remember collapsing uh then it you can
show that like extracting with high
probability also will allow you to
extract without disturbing the state
essentially by measure by essentially by
running the high probability extractor
as a unitary and only measuring the
outputs that you wanted and as long as
the extractor itself
is like a a uh a collapsing like map
then uh you can uh show this doesn't
disturb anything and and undo
uh and this will allow you to like
obtain the thing that you wanted without
uh disturbing the state for example if
the thing you wanted to extract was just
information theoretically determined and
unique then
certainly just like running the
extractor as a unitary measuring the
outputs and undoing it will not have
measured anything at all
uh but this crucially relies on the fact
that the extractor has very high success
for
uh and then that lets you just use your
knowledge for this protocol because for
this gni protocol because you have
guaranteed extraction
you can run the guaranteed extractor
coherently undo the computation and then
simulate without having to disturb the
verifier state
and then finally
uh this requires like
uh
like like there is some like
important thing to understand about this
like reduction which looks trivial like
just do your computation coherently
uh and the issue is that because
the guaranteed extractors not have a
fixed running time
uh it's like you have to be careful
about arguing about what's like doing
this computation coherently actually
means
like normally we make the approximation
that like efficient computation equals
efficient unitary
but if your computation had variable
running time then like depending on your
definition of efficiency this may or may
not actually be true
and so what you actually need
for
to like to have expected polynomial time
simulation for this
like type of protocol is a notion of
expected polynomial time that will allow
you to sort of preserve this property
under purification under like under like
the like converting to a unitary
and it turns out that there's a very
reasonable notion of expected polynomial
time that we come up with called uh
coherent expected polynomial time uh
which precisely allows like like allows
this kind of computation like in the
model
uh and i should mention that's as far as
i can tell nobody has defined expected
quantum polynomial time before
uh which is kind of surprising to me but
like if you if you look for example at
the paper defining bqp they're like
quantum turing machines better run in
fixed time or else things are weird and
so we will just assert that quantum
turing machines must run for a fixed
amount of time when defining efficient
computation and so in order to actually
like
get zero knowledge for these protocols
it turns out that you have to revisit
these foundations and actually like
understand what's going on
and uh and this is provably necessary
because there's actually an
impossibility results
uh
showing
there's actually an impossibility i
can't find the slide for it right now
but there's actually an impossibility
result saying that if you do not
basically consider this kind of
uh expected polynomial time then
simulation is actually impossible
so
this model turns out to be like uh
the model that we come up with turns out
to be a pretty tight characterization of
like what you need in order to have
xeronaut simulation for a bunch of
protocols that that classically were
considered
uh and so that's it so so just now
we
like showed how to do simulation for
zero knowledge by extraction where the
bulk of the work was getting extraction
with very high probability
and this was done by using fast singular
vector algorithms and by thinking of the
tr of the transcript generation problem
itself as a singular vector algorithm as
well
uh and then to get simulation we need to
like use a notion of polynomial time of
the expected polynomial time that allows
for coherence implementations of the
expected polynomial time maps
uh and then so i just had some final
thoughts on just like the entire day of
conversation just like a few things that
you might want to think about so i've
listed them here but like it'd be really
nice to be able to start giving like
more general conditions on when
cryptographic security properties
actually can just be post quantum if you
plug in post quantum assumptions
uh it seems that the
given everything that just happened i
think hopefully it's clear that there's
a lot of like interesting connections
going on between like cryptographic
security properties and
quantum algorithms that like
establishing cryptographic security
properties seem to be pretty tightly
related to different kinds of at least
singular vector algorithms
and uh and the i think the relationship
is probably actually bi-directional like
i think like variants of these like uh
like kinds of amplitude amplification
problems in fact were formalized even
after for example watrus like wrote down
his his algorithm it was like understood
the abstractions were understood after
watchers wrote down a zero knowledge
so yeah i think this this interplay is
is really nice and i expect we'll learn
some more cool things in the future
about it and finally collapsing is a
really important notion to understand
better and understanding when collapsing
actually exists in the world sounds like
a really interesting question to me and
then finally
the in the in the very last talk that
like we didn't get to talk about it but
computational models even ended up
becoming important and understanding
like more precisely what's computational
models characterize security properties
also seems like a worthwhile effort so
thanks thanks for listening and let me
know if you have any
so questions take a
question someplace uh yeah of course
people can go
you're not stuck here
um